thank you so much for this beautiful
honor I want to dedicate this award to
all of my brothers out there all of my
sisters out there inspiring me marching
and fighting for change your voices are
being heard and you're proving to our
ancestors that their struggles were not
in vain in a heartfelt speech Beyonce
gave fans a call to action as she
accepted the Humanitarian Award at the
2020 Beatty Awards
now we have one more thing we need to do
to walk in our true power and that is to
vote I'm encouraging you to continue to
take action continue to change and
dismantle a racist and unequal system we
have to continue to do this together
continue to fight for each other and
lift each other up because there are
people banking are not staying at home
during local elections and primaries
happening in states across the country
we have to vote like our life depends on
it because it does Beyonce was honored
for her charitable work specifically the
work with her be good foundation I am
here today to talk about the Queen you
know the one ever since she was a little
girl in Houston beyonce knowles Carter
has been lighting up the stages and
gracing the world with her town the
beautiful presentation was kicked off by
former First Lady Michelle Obama
so to my girl I just want to say you
inspire me you inspire all of us which
is why I'm so proud to name Beyonce the
20/20 Beatty Awards humanitarian of the
year honoree congratulations girl love
you so much
Beyonce's mother Tina Knowles Lawson and
Tyler Perry also shared their thoughts
on why she is so deserving of this honor
she's always had a humanitarian attitude
she just knows that she has a
responsibility because she's been
blessed to give back listen
easier to be a superstar and take all
your money and go live your life and not
think about anybody else but it's one
with heart
it's a superstar with heart with soul
with kindness that really changes the
world eight-year-old Blue Ivy also had a
big night she took home her very first
beats he Award for her part in her mom's
song brown-skinned girl Blue Ivy's win
and Beyonce's powerful acceptance speech
comes on the same day she announced that
she's partnering with Disney Plus to
share her new visual album black is king
which drops July 31st
[Music]
[Music]
the ancestors never left you the film
which was written directed and executive
produced by Beyonce is based on the
music from her album The Lion King the
gift and it will include some of the
album's featured artists as well as some
special guest appearances
Beyonce's camp released a statement
along with the news of black it's king
saying quote the visual album reimagines
the lessons of the Lion King for today's
young kings and queens in search of
their own crowns the statement goes on
to say quote black is king is an
affirmation of a grand purpose with lush
visuals that celebrate black resilience
and culture the film highlights the
beauty of tradition and black excellence
black is King is just the latest
artistic move Beyonce has made to bring
attention to black excellence as cause
to end systemic racism and police
brutality continue around the world
earlier this month she surprised fans
with her empowering new song Black
Parade in honor of June team
water down on Instagram she wrote quote
happy Juneteenth weekend I hope we
continue to share joy and celebrate each
other even in the midst of struggle
please continue to remember our beauty
strength and power Black Parade
celebrates you your voice and your joy
and will benefit black owned small
businesses